I wanted to just lay out the basics of
what we ought to be doing to get out of
this pickles and I actually think that
school is the thing that we should be
shooting for we should be shooting to be
in a situation where we can afford to
open up school on the far side of this
okay and so I mean it's very simple you
need to tell us that we're gonna lock
down at the maximum possible level for
something like six weeks right now
obviously it can't be a hundred percent
you have to be able to go to the
hospital but by and large if we had
enough warning people could stock up
whatever financial resources were
necessary in order to allow people to
stock up could be generated and then
it's a question of you know if you have
spent time at the beach you hold your
breath and you go under the wave right
six weeks or something of the maximum
conceivable the maximum plausible
lockdown that causes the virus to bounce
whatever routes it has and burn itself
out for the most part won't be a hundred
percent but it will be closed right and
then intense testing and tracing on the
far end with with dealing with flare ups
as spot fires basically and I would say
if this can't be done at a national
level for some reason and frankly it was
the right thing to do months ago and it
remains the right thing to do even
though it's now harder then it is not
inconceivable to me at least that
individual states could decide to solve
their problem and the difficulty with
that is then they have to police their
borders right and that may not even be
constitutional because the nature of our
Federation is that citizens can move
freely between the states but at some
level if this is an epidemiological
crisis just the same way that crises
result in a modification of the way we
see your constitutional rights in
general we might have to do something in
a state that doesn't want to be dragged
down by a country that can't figure out
how to do a lockdown might decide you
know what we're gonna solve it in
Montana right we're gonna solve it in
Oregon
and then I mean imagine the following
thing look folks on the right typically
are the ones advocating the laboratory
of the states is this great idea I'm
often skeptical of it because of the bad
game theory but imagine the good game
theory the race to the top that emerges
of a state figures out how to solve this
problem and suddenly that state gets to
go back to work right
imagine the advantage to the state that
figures out how to solve this problem
the kids get to go back to school the
workers get to go back to work the
economy fires up in this state that
state and the other states have to
follow suit so you know at some level
laboratory of the states is often a
catastrophe with respect to things like
taxes where we race to the bottom and
nobody can collect the taxes to do the
basic stuff but in this case it could be
race to the top and we should seriously
consider it alright this is a very long
pause yeah no I we've talked about this
and what I said earlier is it's true
it's if it was too late then it's even
more too late now and yet it's also true
that I have the extraordinarily human
reaction of oh my god no like we can't
but I also know that we won't and that's
of mitigating my reaction which is awful
because the mitigation of the reaction
is just an understanding that this is
like politically not viable well so
here's the thing right it's still summer
in the in the northern hemisphere and
lockdown could mean go outside right
lockdown doesn't have to meet lockdown
in the winter look I think we got away
with something at the tail end of the
last cold season I guess I'm so if
lockdown we're smarter yeah right so you
know in I don't know if it's Portland or
all of Oregon again just because it's
the place where we live and so we know
best all the public swimming pools are
closed when there is again effectively
no or very little evidence that water
becomes infected when you swim in it and
that you can get co19 from swimming in a
pool even with someone who's infected
you know unless unless again it's it's
airborne at you
and we we should be opening up that
stuff even as we and I guess Newsome
Gavin Newsome the Governor of California
has just as of yesterday maybe
closed down all all bars again and all
indoor seating in restaurants you know
they did three counties in California
including the one that my mother lives
in were the first to close down and
anywhere in the US and California locked
down pretty effectively shortly
thereafter but then they opened up and
things went haywire but they the entire
thing was just this half-assed mosaic of
oh we're gonna close down beaches why
you're closing down beaches what is
wrong with you people
yeah I could don't close down the
beaches don't close down the pools don't
close down the nature areas don't close
down Columbia River Gorge many of the
waterfall waterfalls you can't go to
waterfalls it can be River Gorge still
this makes no sense so you can we can
say that at the same time that we can
say even though I hate it we may just
need more lockdown but not dumb lockdown
it lockdown needs a rebranding I have to
tell you I've know from the beginning
that that term you know it has this
prison connotation and it's got you know
I don't know what the right version of
this is but the northern hemisphere the
sun is shining we could do this such
that we spend time outside we check back
in with stuff that matters with family
we could commune over the Internet I
mean what a marvelous tool this is if
you're gonna be locked down you can
still talk to people globe wide you know
we have to understand look we've got
advantages let's draw on them now and
let's do what needs to be done so we can
drive this thing to extinction because
otherwise we're just gonna be stuck with
this puzzle for who knows how long and
believe me you do not want to get this
thing and get better based on what that
looks like yeah it's too dangerous
[Music]